SAS Carlson duboff but if we can't see
them we don't know for sure who's
playing
no we'll just assume
it seems like a Magnus opening
but more will black knows E5 Knight G7
but it's also a doom of opening wow it's
both of them
wow
no shenanigans
very serious
no masks as well no masks Magnus is
eating so he's already in Peak
Performance mode
exciting he is wearing a Simon Williams
T-shirt
it's just odd
okay one what are they doing three six
D3
looks slow there's D3
can't say I'm an expert
play before like
have a little fun
I never understood this bishop 35 either
I'm assuming there's some subtleties I
always thought provoking F6 can be such
a big deal but here
the plan seems to be to block this
bishop and go C3 D4
so double goes H6
exchanges which is logical because
there's this weak T5 Square in the
center and the dark Square Bishop
doesn't have access to it but here black
can recapture with the Knights keeping
control over that square so it looks
perfectly fine for black to me
I see three castles
he's trying to occupy it
and with this set of pieces it really
shouldn't be big deal whatsoever in two
of those Knight C6
little surprised guess it's fine but you
could also just go but should be six no
takes takes and why it won't be in time
to get control over the square
magazine six no it's a
sort of standard position where white
has the square and black won't challenge
it because it just went 97 to C6
through to midnight back 27 looks like
normal but Daniel has bigger plans
if he wants to attack
I still don't like how he played this
there's Nitro C6 back isn't open
does he play Knight E7 at some point
again
yeah he could have kept it there
magnum's shuffling around he put the
bishop here once the Knight to jump to
C4
some point I'm assuming we'll get F5 and
some some action
also custom plates
H3
which
was a normal move like 15 years ago but
nowadays you just go H4 if you can move
the edge Pawn just push two squares
yeah very old school
and he is aware of Simon Williams so
I'm not sure where he's wearing the
T-shirt yeah
teacher says just resign that's
aggressive
strong strong message
Rook to B8 should still go H4
but he probably won't do it
what's the normal Planet 22 and B4
you think about it Mr word champion
what are you rooting for
no one yet
again with the no rooting and once again
Magnus
white has Shuffle the pieces around and
the Knight is back on D5
black also did some shuffling
it's time to go F5 come on Daniel
there we are
the gloves are off
is that an expression
it's a weird expression I've never seen
it it's like
if you have a boxing match you don't
take the gloves off randomly at some
point
you might want
but it never happens no
so I don't know where what that
expression is
I think it comes from boxing
but that's why I'm saying it makes no
sense
23 Rook C1 sitting the pawn
it's unpleasant you don't want to move
it because you're giving up this Square
So Daniel will be provoked into action
but Knight D4
compromises structure I could take and
go somewhere
Magnus
has out shuffled him here he takes in
Queen G3
all of a sudden there's no black attack
anymore just weaknesses
boxing gloves are used to protect the
hands not the face
so when the gloves come off you're ready
to damage your hands
and
the opponent's hands as well
you can just look at them on their hands
he could keep us on he could keep his
gloves on
I'm not a big expert on bare knuckle
boxing it's always a topic I want to
research some more but I haven't done it
yet I saw the movie Snatch but I
couldn't understand what they were
saying
thank you
F4
just take into a rook
this doesn't look great
Rock on the seventh rank
it's a good thing I learned from my
system
because it hits stuff
this looks lost
and he was getting our plate
how the other Rock will join
it's typical magma stuff like he doesn't
sacrifice but he slowly moves all his
pieces into dominating attacking
positions then he wins
it's probably a good strategy I'm not
sure how he does it
yeah
I don't know how he does it either
he just knows where stuff should go and
then he puts it there and then he's plus
up yeah I also know the pieces are good
here but somehow he gets them there
without without trouble along the way
foreign
eliminating
the lone Defender
King j8
allowing a double check
double checks are nice because they
can't capture either piece of yours
because then the other takes King no not
H5 looks like a good move
oh and Daniel is allowing himself to be
mated